It turns out that in some languages
out there, people sing when they speak.
So how does that work?
Okay.
When you think of the sounds that
you put together to make a word,
vowels and consonants come to
mind, and that's good usually.
But to build words in tonal
languages like a house or Mandarin,
you need another set of musical pieces
called tones to make meaning. Yes.
These languages pay attention to higher
and lower notes like a singer or a
musician would.
They don't do this by requiring their
speakers to have perfect pitch and hit the
same notes as everyone else every time.
Not everyone who speaks your language
will be a metal soprano after all.
So if it's not about the specific notes,
how do tonal languages use so many tones?
They pay attention to changes in pitch.
A syllable sung higher hot
can mean something different
than that same syllable.
Sun Lower are linguistically.
We would count these as two
different tones, whether you're high,
low or just right in the middle,
you're contrasting steady notes.
These different pitches are
called register tones in the band,
two languages of Africa and
Athabaskan languages like Navajo.
The two basic register tones
are a high tone and a low tone.
Changes in pitch can get more
dynamic, rising, falling, bouncing,
or staying level like they
do in mandarin or Vietnamese.
These tones are more about
the shape of the tone,
not simply whether the
note stays high or lower,
so they're called contour
tones. In Mandarin,
a syllable can be pronounced in four
different contour tones. In Tai,
there are five contour tones.
Think you've mastered register versus
contour tones. Well then combine them.
Mandarin may have four contrary tones,
but look to the south to see how Cantonese
distinguishes a low rising tone from
a medium rising tone. Oh, and
it also has a high level tone,
which is different from a medium
level tone and a low level tone.
Add in that low falling tone and
you've got six ways to sing a Cantonese
syllable. Notice that both register
and contoured tones are some on valves.
Continents have your
tongue blocking, smacking.
We're pushing the airflow around.
Unlike this smooth vibrating
air characteristic of valves,
which makes them the perfect
environment for sing song. Eat tones.
Tones are an extra feature that
tonal languages use to build words.
Rising level and falling
are as distinct as PT and k.
So speaking of word in the wrong tone in
one of these languages can sound as bad
as putting a keyword doesn't belong.
This makes tonality in the tutorial.
A really difficult feature to pick
up for people coming from a non tonal
language like English,
much sympathy my friend.
So keep your ears alert and
practice, practice, practice.
Thanks again for learning with
me and subscribed for language.
Okay.